[Applaudissements]
la seule question que se posent les
Français à la suite de votre nomination
à Matignon c'est est-ce que ça va
changer quelque chose pour nous la
France est toujours connaî toujours une
dette habysale qui la place au bord de
la faillite les Français ont de plus en
plus de mal à boucler leur fin de mois
nos frontières sont toujours des
passoirs la violence explose on ne peut
plus se faire soigner dans de nombreux
départements nos épades manquent de tout
et on a désormais une crise du logement
sans précédent avec des salariés
condamnés à dormir dans leur voiture vos
défis c'est peu de le dire sont immenses
le seul remède c'est d'agir avec courage
même quand c'est difficile même quand
c'est impopulaire nous nous sommes
quittés en décembre sur l'adoption de la
loi immigration elle a suscité une crise
qui a fait imploser votre majorité qui a
fait imploser le gouvernement de Madame
borne oui notamment sur la question de
l'aide médicale d'État cette aide
sociale versée au bénéfice de
400000 clandestin coûte 1,2 milliards
aux Français C mêmes français à qui vous
demandez de contribuer de manière
supplémentaire de 50 centimes de plus
par boîte de médicaments ou ces Français
à qui vous dérembourser un peu plus les
soins dentaires votre prédécesseur
monsieur le Premier ministre ainsi que
le ministre de l'Intérieur votre
Ministre de l'Intérieur s'était engagé
devant la représentation nationale à
enfin réformer laame pour la recentrer
sur des soins d'urgence et des soins
vitaux allez-vous tenir cet engagement
quand nous présenterez-vous un projet de
loi je vous remercie monsieur le
Président la parole est à Monsieur le
Premier
[Applaudissements]
Ministre
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le Président
marlex c'est la première fois que je
m'exprime dans cet hémicycle en tant que
Premier ministre et vous me permettrez
de commencer en remerciant le président
de la République pour sa confiance en
remerciant les membres du gouvernement
que j'ai proposé qui ont été nommés de
m'accompagner en remerciant la
représentation nationale pour son
accueil parmi
vous monsieur le Président
marlex en choisissant de me nommer
Premier ministre le président de la
République a choisi de nommer un
ministre du précédent gouvernement
parfaitement lucide sur la situation que
traverse notre pays et les Français oui
notre pays traverse de très grands défis
comme le monde oui des Français
traversent de très grandes difficultés
oui il y a des Français qui doutent il y
a des Français qui souffrent il y a des
Français en colère des Français qui n'y
croient plus et je le dis je ne tomberai
jamais dans le fatalisme consistant à
penser que les problèmes des Français ne
peuvent pas être réglés au contraire
parce que nous voyons aussi chaque jour
dans notre pays des Français qui euh
innovent qui investissent qui
travaillent qui s'engagent dans des
associations en solidarité avec les
Français des Français qui cherchent tout
simplement à faire progresser notre pays
et à répondre aux attentes de leurs
concitoyens et je suis l'un d'entre eux
et les membres de de mon gouvernement le
sont également j'aurai l'occasion
évidemment de présenter ma déclaration
de politique générale et nous aurons
l'occasion d'avancer sur un certain
nombre de chantiers ensemble je le dis
je suis lucide sur ces
difficultés est totalement mobilisé pour
y répondre notamment celle que vous avez
évoqué vous avez posé une question
s'agissant de l'immigration de notre
modèle social et de l'aide médicale
d'État un texte a été débattu au
Parlement un texte a été adopté le
Conseil constitutionnel en est saisi et
se prononcera
prochainement dans le cadre de ce texte
un débat sur l'aide médicale d'État
ellisabeth borne ma prédécesseur a
effectivement adressé un courrier en
prenant un engagement et cet engagement
sera tenu monsieur le Président marlex
j'aurai l'occasion dans ma déclaration
de politique générale à revenir sur les
chantiers à venir sur la méthode de
travail mais vous l'aurez compris je
souhaite avancer avancer vite avancer
fort sur les préoccupations de nos
concitoyens pour permettre à notre pays
d'affronter les grands défis qui sont
devant lui je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le Premier ministre
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
les beau mots c'est bien l'action c'est
mieux je vous rappelle que l'ame c'est
l'argent des Français ces Français à qui
vous demandez un effort sur leur
dépenses de santé il n'est pas de raison
que vous ne passiez pas très vite à
l'action sur laame on l'attend pour ce
début de l'année comme promis par votre
prédécesseur merci
beaucoup